hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today I'm going
to be taking you through another game
from the Tata Steel Masters Tournament
now Ali's le Reza's fruga has been a
very hot topic in chess lately he's had
some very very strong results but
unfortunately he had to go up against
Wesley so in this game and Wesley so a
world-class player has been for some
time now really managed to demonstrate
the gap that still exists between ali
reza and these top top players and let's
see how he did that the game started
with d4 d5 c4 now the rezident played
the queen's gambit accepted Wesley so
plays Knight f3 a move aimed at stopping
this ePHI break Knight f6 III g6 white
recaptures this pawn without too much
controversy black plays c5 in after
castles a3 white needs to develop this
Bishop it doesn't look like it's gonna
come out through this diagonally
thanks to the ski three pawn being in
the way so Wesley plays b3 and prepares
to bring the bishop out to the long
diagonal C takes d4 Knight takes d4
Bishop e7 Bishop b2 very natural
developing moves from both sides
castles this Bishop actually drops back
to e to anticipating a b5 break in the
near future
now after Bishop d7 92 and 96 we kind of
see both sides finishing the development
of their minor pieces and this position
looks boring I'm not gonna lie to you it
looks as though there are two open files
on the board the pawn structure is
totally symmetrical there's not much to
play for the players should agree to a
draw from this position call it a day go
home get some sleep but the reality is
this position is terrifying for both
sides and the reason for that is chess
when it's centered around pawn breaks
and easy to understand plans is is very
simple not very simple but pretty simple
right you know what you're playing for
you know what your opponents playing for
and both of you kind of understand
what's going on and it's just a question
of who kind of gets there first but
chess in these types of positions are
where 2,800 level players and near 2,800
level players really show their class
that's because this position is all
about piece activity and so what Wesley
is gonna try to do here is make sure
that his pieces remain more active doing
more things than his opponents despite
the symmetrical structure and he starts
by playing very very natural moves
simply rook c1 bringing this rook to the
C file and we see York c8 from ali reza
this knight retreats to f3 know that
these pieces are kind of stepping on
each other's toes white or black would
love to have these Knights off the board
and to bring this bishop to c6 so Wesley
retreats this night making sure this
awkward Knight has to stick around for a
little bit longer black plays b5 now I
don't know if you've heard this
principle before but the way it the way
to play against Knights is to take away
their outposts and their advancing moves
so Wesley plays a3 preventing any night
before any time in the future black
decides he needs to find a square for
this Queen he chooses to be six square
and now Wesley simply plays rook c2 and
already it looks as though both players
have just played some some very natural
moves but but Wesley has really done a
lot one of the main main things that I
can't stress enough is this night for to
f3 move this move is really actually
giving a lyricism some headaches here I
think and the reason is this awkward
bishop on d7 this is just like the one
nagging problem that that ali reza kind
of has to solve and if ali reza doesn't
doesn't solve its if we plays like rook
d8 or something
Wesley might continue with a move like
Queen 2 b1
he's just going to double up his his
rooks he's going to bring this bishop to
a better Square and this bishop is going
to remain the worst piece on the board
for either side and that's going to be a
problem so what ali reza does is he
commits he
it's to the movie fight and this is a
move that is slightly double-edged as
soon as you touch this epon there's no
moving it back obviously the obvious
upside to this move is that it allows
this bishop to breathe a little bit and
gives it these three squares to choose
from and any one of these squares will
honestly do the job for black gets this
bishop active and out of the way on the
D file so the black rooks can come to
life now what's the downside to this
move well it puts this pawn on e5 where
it's much less safe than the e6 square
you might notice immediately it's
attacked twice and only defended once
for the moment ali reza has some
tactical ideas of recapturing this a3
pawn in exchange and this would be
playable for black but what wesley does
is is very very mean like I said once
this pawn moves here there's no moving
it back so West is actually in no rush
to to capture this pawn he if black
wants to defend this pawn he's more than
happy to allow that because black will
have to commit his pieces to a defensive
stance and that really limits their
activity which is what this game is all
about so Wesley simply plays Bishop d3
taking away the best square for the for
the black Bishop and after rook f d8
Queen e2 defends this bishop from any
potential threats Ali rez it brings this
Bishop to g4 simply rook see one like I
said Wesley is in no rush to clarify the
situation in this epoch Knight a 7 is
actually a lenez's fatal mistake here it
doesn't look like a fatal mistake it
looks like a very natural move ali reza
just wants to trade off the rooks get
closer to the type of position that can
be more easily drawn and it's this
impatience is this desire to to clarify
things where we're wrestling so has
really shown himself to be the better
player here if ali reza simply continued
playing natural chests queen b 7 defends
this rook eyes these light squares and
tandem with the bishop ali rez is still
totally fine here and I have no doubt
Wesley would find more you know simple
improving waiting
to try and continue this game but after
night a seven Wesley does have some
concrete ways to gain an advantage and
he does so via rook takes e8 Rick takes
c8 rook takes see it and it takes c8 and
age three so of course if this bishop
were to retreat to somewhere like e6000
plea actually hanging now and there's no
recapturing pawns on this side of the
board as they're defended similar story
if Bishop h5 will just simply do this
first and then go ahead and capture this
pawn so this Bishop has to take this
night and now after Queen f3 white does
have the bishop pair and that might not
seem like a lot but against Wesley so
it's it's enough and Wesley really
proves that in this game so what's the
difference between this line and the
line with Queen b7 well by keeping this
rook on the board you're keeping this
pressure on the d3 bishop
so if white tries the same thing you
can't recapture with the Queen because
you leave the bishop behind so you would
have to take back with the pawn and
maybe you can try this with white to
play for an advantage but obviously
you're giving up a lot so night a7 Ali
Reza's first mistake and now we achieve
this position which still doesn't look
like much but like I said against Leslie
so it's kind of enough Queen d8 is what
firoozeh played Queen e2 for Wesley
defending this Bishop Queen d5 looking
for activity simply Bishop c2 defending
this pawn and opening up this Queen to
look at the King side is where the Queen
side as well 96 Wesley's not afraid of a
queen trade here it takes takes simply
97g for Wesley expands a little bit now
on the Kings side cg 694 offers up a
trade on the Knights takes takes and
we're approaching the pure endgame of
two bishops against Bishop and night I'm
sorry not not Bishop d5 here but rather
Bishop C - and now ali reza commits to
another weakness with E for and this is
kind of kind of the last mistake once
this pawn is on e for free is going to
have a very very difficult time
maintaining this pawn perhaps a better
try would be to go for this structure
which is slightly more compact and
slightly more easily defendable by
having this pawn on a dark square closer
your King you can always defend it with
things like king of 76 and the endgame
might be holed a ball although it is
looking quite nice for white but okay
after E for Wesley continues very
accurately B for forces this Knight to
d3 to block off this Bishop this Bishop
simply moves to c3
now King f8 King f1 f5 desperately
trying to defend this pawn and Wesley
could have taken here but instead he
plays King e2 and now after Bishop d8
Bishop takes d3 he takes d3 King takes
d3 Wesley is simply up upon and it
manages to win this game with very good
technique king f7 e 4 is his choice and
now F takes G 4 isn't really the best
holding try perhaps at 4 would have
given Wesley a little bit more of a
fight but after takes takes white simply
has a passed pawn here and king D 4 is
the nice move to really seal ferocious
fate if you give Bishop f6 check I'll
block with E 5 if you give Bishop b6
check thinking you're winning upon well
you're correct you are winning upon but
my King is far too fast on the Queen
side and this game very quickly ended in
Wesley so's favor
a4 was the key move for white here
creating a passed pawn this Bishop will
always guard the a1 square and this pawn
is going to be difficult to stop
especially after fridge herb sorry
Wesley's next move Bishop e5
highlighting that white controls every
square along the path for the pawn and
after
v5 fruga simply resigned here due to the
fact that Wesley is queening by force
and so this game once again shows the
class of Wesley so and shows that gap
that freesia still needs to overcome to
become a truly elite top-10 player
freesia at just 16 years of age a very
impressive chess player and I have no
doubt in the years to come we'll see him
playing games like the white side of
this one thank you very much for joining
me today on game review my name is Caleb
Denby and I'll see you in the next
episode